So once it became clear that the El Paso shooter
was a right wing or radical
lies by many of the same ideas that have been
fomented by this administration leaving a
right wing manifesto, Republicans had to rally
around something else, some other talking
point.
And the talking point they chose basically
was video games.
We've got to do something about video games
with some vague mentions of social media in
the background.
Uh, for credibility sake, I guess.
And we're going to get into some of these
examples now just to reminder, this video
is going to be demonetized on Youtube.
Almost all of today's show will be demonetized
on youtube because it's a show about shootings,
terrorism, radicalization, important stuff.
I've spoke to some other shows.
Some people are choosing not to cover this.
In order to retain monetization, we've got
to cover this stuff.
Okay, so I'm asking you, leave us a tip today,
become a member@joinpacman.com uh, to help
out with the fact that today's show is going
to be a Freebie in the sense of a no revenue
show.
So they bring this tired trope of video games,
caused people to become radicalized and violent
and go out and act out all of that violence
in the real world.
Here's just one short example from Fox News.
Darren, what about video games?
So many of these school shooters and others
have been sort of raised on a diet of violent
video games.
Now this has been studied.
Video Games may, may cause already a violent
people or people predisposed to violence to
go out into the world in some cases and commit
a real world act of violence that they've
already been predisposed to and potentially
have even been thinking about.
But video games, by and large are not causing
violence in otherwise nonviolent people.
They will not indoctrinate perfectly reasonable
people into the anti-immigrant, Zenith phobic
white nationalists delusions of the El Paso
shooter.
And this came up again when a Texas Lieutenant
Governor Dan Patrick went on Fox News, take
a look at this.
And I and I look at this evil act and let's
condemn it for what it is.
Evil, evil and I, and I, and I say, how long
are we going to let for example, and ignore
at the federal level, particularly where they
can do something about the video game industry.
You know, in this manifesto that we believe
is from the shooter, this manifesto, he talks
about living out his super soldier fantasy
on call of duty,
another Republican Kevin McCarthy also on
the Video Game Talking Point Bandwagon.
And sometimes they try to temper it a little
bit by talking about social media, which does
present a whole slate of issues societaly
but that really shouldn't be mixed in with
this video game talking point.
Take a look.
But what, what are your thoughts on that in
terms of understanding that words matter and
that when we're talking to each other on social
media or looking at video games where they're
using, you know, uh, videos of, uh, of characters
with these, uh, weapons, is there a conversation
to be had about that, about the tone that,
that this country is using it to become commonplace,
to say whatever you want to anybody on social
media?
I think we should.
And you want to see from these individuals
what they wrote in others.
But I mean, um, this may be a place that we
could find this ahead of time.
There may be a place of what what's being
written.
Um, can be changed, could be an indication
that an individual needs help and others that
we can stop.
But the idea of these video games to de-humanize
individuals to have a game of shooting individuals
and others, I've always felt that as a problem
for, um, future generations and others.
Uh, we, we watched from studies shown before
of what it does to individuals.
Um, when you look at these photos of how it
took place, um, you, you can see the actions
within video games and others.
But what I'd like to do is make sure just
get all the facts
so we don't have to pretend that violence
in movies in video games has zero no effect
on anyone culturally in any way.
But the El Paso shooter is a guy radicalized
around specific radical right wing ideologies.
People who play video games and aren't radicalized
by the stuff that Trump has been spewing aren't
going to go out and commit violence like this.
I did a twitch stream last night, by the way,
you should be following me there.
twitch.tv/david Pacman.
And people asked me, do I play video games?
And I said, you know, I don't play very many
video games, but the one that I've been playing
since I was quite young are the different
iterations of grand theft auto, one of the
most violent games that is out there.
And there was absolutely no connection whatsoever
between the cartoonish violence and the game
and anything that I've ever even considered
doing in the real world.
And importantly, you know, other countries
have video games.
Look at Japan and look at the fact that there
are basically no shootings in Japan.
Uh, every country has racist people.
Uh, every country has atheists for those who
want to blame the fact that you know, God
is no longer in school.
Every country has mental illness.
W other countries don't have the problems
that we have even though they have lots of
these other ancillary characteristics and
there are also more general crime statistics
to consider.
Remember that video game playing in the United
States has gone up for decades.
Violence in total has also been going down
for decades.
The general trend is video games up, violence
down, so we have to look at the nitty gritty
and the particulars of the types of shootings
that we're actually having and again, just
as importantly by proportion there is just
as much video gaming and other countries and
those countries don't have our mass shooting
problems.
This same guy, Dan Patrick, the Texas lieutenant
governor went on another Fox News show and
said we've got to really be careful about
antifa and TIF has got to stay away as if
that has anything to do whatsoever with this
shooting.
And again, law enforcement you on the basic
thing.
That's just been an amazing thing as your
guest.
I just start a little bit of your previous
guests talking about the client scene and
you know one does one or two people shot.
You can imagine the size of this crime scene
and this will be an investigation that will
take some time.
Um, you know, this, uh, you know, I was, I
was, uh, looking at a story recently, uh,
but just saw in the last couple of days where
antica is, is posting, you know, they want
to come to El Paso and do a 10 day siege,
um, clear message, van t for stat of El Paso,
um, stat a Texas basically, but we don't need,
uh, them coming in on September 1st.
We didn't need them to begin with before this
happened, but I would, uh, I would say to
Antifa, uh, scratch Texas off your map and
don't come in.
Uh, it is not the time and place for them
to come at anytime, but particularly in the
aftermath of what's just happening in El Paso.
So antifa message from Lieutenant Governor,
stay out of Texas.
Now, you know, I've never defended Antifa
or any political violence, but the idea of
saying, given that a guy just mass shot and
killed 20 people and injured many more on
the basis of this right wing anti-immigrant,
Zena phobic white nationalist ideology, uh,
now I should also mention we don't need antifa
here as if there's some kind of equivalency
between the two groups.
And of course in the background of every single
one of these clips, what's the elephant in
the room?
It's never guns.
And that's likely the motivation for the fact
that so many Republicans are jumping on the
video game talking point.
It's never guns and that we shouldn't talk
about, but it's also never right wing radicalization
either.
That also not coming up.
It's video games and we've got to be careful
about Antifa.
And next we literally have the juxtaposition
of interrupting right wing radicalization
to report on a right wing shooting.
And of course never mentioning that the shooter
actually left a right wing manifesto.
Let's talk
about
that next.